when people think of the American Wild
West several ideas often spring to mind
saloons conflict between cowboys and
Native Americans a general sense of
lawlessness and people being tied up to
railroads for some inexplicable reason
the prevailing idea is that the Wild
West was well wild but how true is this
view just how wild was the Wild West
just to clear up some dates when most
people are talking about the Wild West
there mostly referencing the period
between 1848 when the u.s. gained these
lands up until the early 20th century so
we'll go through these common images of
the Wild West one at a time first of all
saloons were very common since everybody
liked to drink but a couple of
misconceptions exist one most saloons
had regular doors because the Old West
was dusty and also because you want to
lock the door sometimes yes they did
serve booze it was expensive yes there
was gambling it caused problems and yes
there were prostitutes but they weren't
exactly ever-present so just how wild
worthy saloons
they weren't most of them were
essentially workers clubs and it was
more likely you'd hear about marks then
see a mass brawl but what about Cowboys
then do they match up to the common
image that we have of them nope Cowboys
were ranches and worked to keep cattle
safe from predators and the occasional
thief now Cowboys all over the American
West did develop a culture of suspicion
of outsiders and of loutish violence
which led to many people who stayed in
small frontier towns being accosted by
local ranch workers sometimes they would
be robbed sometimes they would be
assaulted and sometimes the locals acted
up to play up to the stereotype what
stereotype well along the East Coast
many people were fascinated with the
rugged culture that had been developing
and so many journalists traveled to the
frontier to provide stories which they
promptly exaggerated and something not
often spoken about is the fact that
Cowboys had bosses and those bosses
weren't too keen on the whole violence
thing hence why when Cowboys were caught
misbehaving they were fired as for the
cowboys and Indians trope Native
Americans were treated horrendously by
those moving westward however most of
the violence towards them wasn't between
natives and roaming gangs of cowboys and
bandits it was between them and the
central government who could and did
exert considerable force in the West
which brings us onto law and order
there's a common idea of constant Jews
robberies and a general sense of
lawlessness which was caused by there
only being one share of every 100 square
miles often sheriffs would be aided by
several others in their duties and also
being a sheriff was quite boring
when say looking at California during
the gold rush most crime was
alcohol-related and there was very
little in the way of serious violence
although criminal gangs did exist
especially in the south
however the central government was able
to exert pretty considerable control
over the area despite the sheer empty
distances if crime got too bad the
central government or the state
government could quickly clamp down on
it because governors and politicians
don't like to look bad and want to be
re-elected and us for the whole tying
people to railroads thing its originated
as a trope of fiction in what were
called dime novels which were incredibly
popular and yes this did actually happen
to people but one it happened all over
the US not just in the West and - it
happened about five times over a 50-year
period and so to answer the question how
wild was the Wild West the answer is
well a little just as wild as the
American East or say rural Italy was at
the time the fact is for most Americans
living on the frontier life was very
similar to that back in the east for
every cowboy there was a miner or a
furniture maker and the small mining
town was often all things considered
pretty boring I hope you enjoyed this
episode and thank you for watching with
the special thanks to my patreon
supporters James Bissonnette Colin
Castleman Danny Maloney Marvin Castle
Rob Waterhouse John BJ's Mo Aaron the
white Michael Reynolds James Castaneda
Gustav Swann Marcus Ozma Jordan Longley
James Castaneda Gustav Swann Marcus Ozma
Jordan Longley Gareth Turner mr. show
Rashid Ali spinning three plates filled
- oink oink David Silverman Izzy
Winston Cawood Maggie packs Kowski Lexi
Schwinn Spencer Lightfoot Kelly
moneymaker
Robert Wetzel Skye Chappelle and Anthony
Beckett